i have to ask you about gulag
archipelago by solji nitzin
that speak to this very point there's so
many layers to this book who could talk
about it forever
i'm sure in many ways we are talking
about it forever
uh but there is sort of one of the
themes captured in a few ways that was
described to the book is that line
between good and evil that runs through
every
human being
as he writes
uh
the line dividing good and evil cuts to
the heart of every human being
during the life of any heart this line
keeps changing place
sometimes it is squeezed one way to
exuberant evil and sometimes it shifts
to allow enough space for good to
flourish
one and the same human being is at
various ages under various circumstances
a totally different human being
at times he is close to being a devil
at times to sainthood
but his name doesn't change
and to that name we ascribed a whole lot
good and evil what do you think about
this line what do you think about this
thing what we talked about if you give
somebody a chance you actually bring out
the best in them what do you think about
this other aspect
that throughout time
that line shifts inside each person and
you get to define that shift what do you
think about this line
are we all capable of evil
well you know the cosmic drama that's
satan versus christ
it's like well who's that about
if it's not about you
i i'm speaking just as a psychologist or
as a literary critic those are
characters at least they're that
well are they human characters
well obviously
well are they archetypal human
characters
yes what does that mean
cosmically and ontologically
i don't know
gives the world a story
maybe but the way stories are often told
is the characters and body i know those
are those are
not great literature though
it's very rare in great literature what
you have in great literature generally
is the internal drama right in
as the literature becomes more pop i
would say
the characters are more unitary so
there's a real bad guy and he's all bad
and there's a real good guy and he's all
good
and that's not as interesting it's not
as sophisticated
if when you reach dostoevsky in heights
in in literary representation or
shakespearean heights
you can identify with the villain
and that's that's when literature re
really reaches its pinnacle in some
sense and also the characters change
throughout the shift they're
unpredictable throughout
taking the speaking of russia more
seriously recently
and i've gotten to talk to translators
of dostoevsky and tolstoy and um
czechov and those kinds of folks and you
get to
one of the mistakes that translators
made with dostoevsky for the longest
time
is they would
quote unquote fix
the chaotic mess that is dostoyevsky
because
there was a sense like he was too rushed
in his writing it seemed like there was
tangents that had nothing to do with
anything the characters were
unpredictable not inconsistent there's
parts of phrases that seem to be
incomplete that kind of stuff and what
they realize that is that's not that's
actually crafted that way it's not it's
you know it's like editing james joyce
like finnegan's wake or something
because it doesn't make any sense they
realize that that is the magic of it
that captures the humanity of these
characters that they are unpredictable
they change through all time
there's a bunch of contradictions
you